It's been a long time since
Leonardo, Donatello, Raphael,
and Michaelangelo appeared on the big screen,
so there's a lot of catching up to do. Here's
everything you need to know about the upcoming
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles: Mutant Mayhem.
"Lob it up, Lob it up."
It's been seven years since Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles: Out of the Shadows arrived
on movie screens in June 2016. After
that film was met with middling reviews,
fans of the franchise would have to wait
until Summer 2023 to see another feature film.
Originally, Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles:
Mutant Mayhem was slated for an August 11,
2023 release. However, in January 2021,
Paramount Pictures announced quite a few
changes to the studio's schedule after emerging
from the pause in theatrical exhibition brought
on by the COVID pandemic. With many major
titles like the Mission: Impossible movies
getting new release dates, Mutant Mayhem was
one of the many films to get pushed around.
Fortunately for Turtles fans, we'll now get to
see the film significantly sooner. Currently,
the movie will hit theaters
on August 2, 2023. However,
Mutant Mayhem will only have two days free
of box office competition before The Meg 2:
The Trench surfaces on August 4. Both will
duke it out at the box office for a couple
of weeks until they receive further theatrical
competition from another young hero, in the form
of DC Comics' Blue Beetle. This new superhero's
live-action debut will be released on August 18.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles: Mutant Mayhem
will focus on the early days of the Turtles'
crime-fighting career as they navigate
the Big Apple and try to show everyone
their heroic intentions. Not only do
they want to be accepted as heroes,
but they seek affirmation and
acceptance as normal teenagers.
"Hey guys? If we weren't monsters that were
shunned by society and we could do what we wanted,
what would you guys do?"
Somehow, the path they choose to normalcy involves
taking down mutant crime boss Superfly. Of course,
the Turtles made a new friend along
the way in the form of April O'Neil,
a human teenager who becomes the group's
most trusted partner in fighting crime.
The four half-shelled brothers and April
find themselves completely out of their
element when Superfly unleashes a
dangerous mutant army upon New York
City with the intention of eliminating all humans.
To save their hometown, the
Turtles, their ingenious friend,
and master Splinter must save the entire city
from mutated villains of all shapes. Some
of those menacing mutants will include the
likes of Bebop and Rocksteady, Leatherhead,
Genghis Frog, Mondo Gecko, Wingnut,
and the mad scientist Baxter Stockman.
Will they be too much for
the Turtles to handle? Well,
we're assuming our ninja buddies will get
the job done, but the movie is definitely
emphasizing their youth and inexperience.
It seems the filmmakers are really trying
to highlight the "teen" element of
our protagonists in this installment.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles: Mutant Mayhem boasts
an A-list cast, with veteran actors and comedians
filling out many of the supporting parts. But
before we start looking at side characters,
who will be playing the star-throwing,
sai-wielding, mask-wearing Turtles?
Nicolas Cantu is playing the leader of the group,
Leonardo. If you're a fan of
The Amazing World of Gumball,
his voice will definitely sound familiar to you
as he played Gumball himself in Seasons 5 and 6.
The brainy Donatello is voiced by Micah Abbey,
who plays Leaf in Nickelodeon's Cousins for
Life. The wisecracking Michelangelo
is portrayed by Shamon Brown Jr.,
who previously starred as Stanley "Papa"
Jackson in The Chi. Finally, the gruff
Raphael is voiced by Brady Noon, who played
Evan Morrow in The Mighty Ducks: Game Changers.
As for the rest, the legendary Jackie Chan plays
Master Splinter, the Turtles' rodent mentor. Ayo
Edebiri of The Bear portrays April O'Neil, our
heroes' human ally. Seth Rogen and John Cena will
voice iconic big baddies Bebop and Rocksteady,
while their fellow mutants will be voiced by
Hannibal Buress as Genghis Frog, Rose Byrne
as Leatherhead, and Paul Rudd as Mondo Gecko.
Post Malone plays the aquatic Ray Fillet,
Natasia Demetriou of What We Do in the
Shadows will keep things batty as Wingnut,
and Giancarlo Esposito will voice mad scientist
and longtime Turtle foe Baxter Stockman.
Some movies would be content to cast Bebop and
Rocksteady opposite the Turtles, maybe throw in
a Shredder scene, and call it a day. Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles: Mutant Mayhem, however,
is going much deeper. In addition to bringing back
a bunch of classic TMNT villains like Leatherhead
and Baxter Stockman, Mutant Mayhem is introducing
at least two new characters to the franchise.
The first is the Ice Cube-voiced Superfly.
"What the — Y'all some little tortoises, huh?"
This mutant fly is the film's overarching
villain and organizer of all the other
vengeful mutants in the Seth Rogen-produced
animated film. In addition to Ice Cube,
actress Maya Rudolph has apparently joined
the cast in the role of Cynthia Utrom.
While the Utroms may be familiar to Turtles fans,
Cynthia is a brand new character. We haven't seen
or heard from her at all in the early trailers,
so we aren't sure exactly what
form Rudolph's character will take.
However, in the TMNT universe, the Utroms are
the alien species that the enemy warlord Krang
belongs to. Perhaps this is a hint at who
the villain of a potential sequel could be.
As the trailer for Mutant
Mayhem proudly proclaims,
the film comes from "permanent teenager"
Seth Rogen. As the movie's co-producer,
Rogen is best known for writing, directing,
and playing goofballs in acclaimed comedies
like Superbad, Pineapple Express, and This Is
the End. Rogen has also produced quite a few of
his films alongside Evan Goldberg and James
Weaver, who join him here as co-producers.
Going into Mutant Mayhem, Rogen has expressed
interest in focusing on the inherent coming-of-age
aspects of the franchise. He explained to Collider
that he always found the adolescent aspects of the
mutant heroes to be the most interesting
part of their story. He elaborated that
the franchise being centered around teens made
this project a perfect match for him, saying,
"As someone who loves teenage movies,
and who's made a lot of teenage movies,
and who literally got their start in their
entire profession by writing a teenage movie,
the idea of kind of honing in on that
element was really exciting to us."
Rogen certainly approached the nearly 40
year-old franchise with a fresh mindset. Even
Ninja Turtles co-creator Kevin Eastman admits
he's pretty psyched to see the film, telling
IGN that he really enjoys Rogen's work and he's
curious to see how he approaches the new movie.
With Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg producing,
you might be wondering who's directing Mutant
Mayhem? The job of shepherding the Turtles
to the big screen has gone to Jeff Rowe,
who co-wrote Netflix's The Mitchells vs. the
Machines. He's also served as a writer on both
Gravity Falls and Disenchantment, proving he's
quite adept at mastering the medium of animation.
Mutant Mayhem is Rowe's directorial debut,
and while praising the film's production
designer on Twitter, Rowe wrote,
"The colors are cool and unexpected. We wanted
to throw out the animation playbook on this one."
Based on the visuals we've seen, it
looks like Mutant Mayhem will stand
alongside the aforementioned Mitchells
vs. the Machines and Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse when it
comes to incredible designs.
Rowe has also compared the film
to some coming-of-age classics,
telling Empire that his team had films
like Stand By Me and Lady Bird in mind
when they were coming up with it. Speaking
about the Turtles themselves he said,
"They've got a lot of that inauthentic confidence
that teenagers have. When you're a teen,
you don't know any better, so you operate with
this hyped-up sense of, 'We can do anything!'"
"I'm awesome."
As for who wrote the script, Rowe, Rogen,
and Goldberg all share credit, along
with Dan Hernandez and Benji Samit.
The first trailers for Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles: Mutant Mayhem features the classic
hip-hop song "Can I Kick It?" by A Tribe Called
Quest. This choice can't help but evoke 1991's
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles II: The Secret of
the Ooze soundtrack, which featured Vanilla Ice's
"Ninja Rap." However, there appears to be more to
the Mutant Mayhem soundtrack than just '90s rap.
According to the film's director and one
rogue celebrity, Trent Reznor and Atticus
Ross of Nine Inch Nails have been tapped to
score Mutant Mayhem. In a funny twist of fate,
the news actually came out after
skateboarding legend Tony Hawk
let it slip while being interviewed on a podcast.
Mutant Mayhem director Jeff Rowe took
to Twitter to get on top of the leak
and announced the official collaboration
with Reznor and Ross on May 28. Rowe wrote,
"Well now that my teenage hero @tonyhawk
has leaked that my music heroes are doing
this I can add that the score is
absolutely AMAZING. Exhilarating,
terrifying, heartbreaking, full
of sounds I didn't know existed."
It's unclear how much of the soundtrack
to Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles:
Mutant Mayhem will be Reznor and
Ross's original work and how much
will be licensed songs from artists in the
vein of "Can I Kick It?" If we had to guess,
we'd say there will likely be a little of
both, but maybe that's wishful thinking.
While you're waiting for Mutant Mayhem, you
might want to catch up on previous Turtle
content — and there's a lot. Unfortunately, the
original Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles cartoon
isn't available to stream anywhere,
but you can purchase it on iTunes.
If you want to see the Turtles in
live-action, you can buy Ninja Turtles:
The Next Mutation on Amazon Prime.
Fans of the 2003 Fox series Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles can check out
all seven seasons on Paramount+,
while fans of the 2012 Nickelodeon series can find
three seasons on Paramount+ and two on Netflix.
And if you're looking for Rise of
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,
various seasons of the series are
available Paramount+ and Netflix.
The first feature film trilogy to
showcase the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles is available to rent on Amazon
Prime, Apple iTunes, Google Play, Vudu,
and YouTube. Each of these platforms also
hosts the animated TMNT film from 2007.
Finally, the first Michael-Bay
produced TMNT movie, released in 2014,
is available to stream on Amazon Prime and
Paramount+. The second and most recent film,
Out of the Shadows, can be streamed
on Paramount+ and Pluto TV.
With so many different shows and movies about
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles over the years,
we get that it's hard for anyone who's not
a hardcore TMNT-head to understand where
the newest animated movie falls in the canon.
Luckily, the answer is surprisingly simple:
we are starting with a clean slate in
a brand new decade for the Turtles.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles: Mutant Mayhem is
not a part of any existing TMNT timeline. The
upcoming animated feature is a full reboot of
the franchise. Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg's
approach of exploring the four turtles as modern
teens requires a full reset of their mythology.
The vibrant art style also marks Mutant
Mayhem as a distinctly new story with new
interpretations of the characters fans
have known and loved since the 1980s.
Mutant Mayhem might be a fresh start, but
there's a high likelihood it won't be the
only animated Turtles in this continuity. If the
movie succeeds, Paramount has already hinted that
it may want more animated films from this
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles franchise.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles: Mutant
Mayhem doesn't hit theaters until August 2,
but there are already whispers
that this stylish new take on
the Turtles is the start of a new
animation initiative at Paramount.
In 2022, Variety asked Paramount Chief
Executive Officer Brian Robbins about
the plans for rebooting the
TMNT series. Robbins replied,
"It's going to work for kids, parents,
Gen Z-ers and millennials. We have plans
to do multiple animated movies this way,
but one day we might go back to a hybrid
live-action version of the Turtles."
This statement shines some light on the future
of the franchise, while still being frustratingly
vague. Robbins teased a return to live-action
Turtles movies, but definitely implied that if
Mutant Mayhem succeeds it will garner sequels. The
phrasing is nebulous enough that Robbins is really
only committing to more animated movies in this
modern Sony Pictures Animation-inspired style.
Regardless of how you want to
interpret Robbins' statement,
if Mutant Mayhem connects with
audiences, it sounds like you can
expect there to be more animated Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movies in the future.